hello welcome today I've got a little
something different going on so I will
put that right there we got a little
high budget set going on here what is
what's going on it what is this
mysterious beverage we'll have to find
out it relates to what we're talking
about today which is Brian rose and his
London freedom platform which is kind of
a joke this is pretty stupid but I'd
like to explain it to you guys because I
think there's been a lot of
miscommunication and misinformation
about what the freedom platform actually
is they may take our lives
but they'll never take digital freedom
platform so what is the freedom platform
it's this crowdfunding campaign that
Brian Rose of London real put together
that ended up raising a million dollars
what started as in $100,000 crowdfunding
campaign that he started just kept
create he just kept creating stretch
goals for it like initially he wanted to
livestream this David Icke interview
because he got super butthurt that it
got banded in YouTube and I don't think
it should have gotten bad so he really
wants to have a conversation with David
Icke again so he goes okay guys we're
gonna do we can't have a conversation on
YouTube let's go ahead and throw it on
the digital freedom platform now little
does Brian Rose know hosting things cost
a lot of money so pretty quickly friends
oh oh this is gonna cost more than I
thought so let me just crowd fund it
instead of using my millions of dollars
that I make every year from selling
business accelerators let's not call it
a part of London real let's call it
something different this platform is of
the people by the people for the people
and so we are creating a separate entity
with its own separate funding we're
gonna crowd fund this it's not it's not
a part of London real even though we'll
host it on the London real website we're
gonna make this this separate thing that
everyone's gonna crowd funds so they
crowd fund a hundred thousand dollars a
lot faster than Brian Rose thought they
would and so he goes okay well let's
just make a bunch of new goals so he
starts pulling goals basically out of
thin air but now we're getting in that
was phase one now we're doing phase 2
phase 3 and I'm moving into phase 4 and
lastly there will be phase 5 like he's
like oh we got 100,000 miles let's raise
$200,000 to have even more controversial
voices on let's bring them all in then
he was like oh well we've raised that so
let's create a blockchain for this new
digital freedom platform which as you'll
see in a moment doesn't make any sense
for what he's actually doing and then
he's like let's raise two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars because I don't
know let's make an app of what I don't
know then he's like well let's raise
$250,000 to take YouTube to court
because freedom freedom guy said I'll be
honest guys out I mean I have nothing
against we had general message that
doesn't change the fact that people
spent a million dollars on Brian roses
form and they didn't get what they
thought they were gonna get because what
do you think when you hear digital
freedom platform probably that it's
online it's all about freedom and it's a
platform right like YouTube is a video
hosting platform you would think that
the digital freedom platform is a
platform of freedom that hosts videos or
live streams or something like that
but it's actually not that and it's also
not independent like Brian rose says it
is again this is about us building
something that we can use for the future
they will never ban us again the reason
I know this is I done some investigation
after a lot of people from Brian roses
camp started to ask me what's going on
with this I feel like Brian roses may be
doing a cash grab and not actually
building what he says he's building so I
looked into it and there's a few things
you should know about the London real
digital freedom platform number one it's
not a technology okay this isn't an
actual platform like YouTube or Vimeo or
something like this Brian Rose has done
nothing except for rely on different
hosting platforms for example instead of
a hosting on YouTube he now hosts a lot
of his videos on his platform on
dailymotion now now how that makes him
independent from censorship and how that
keeps him from being censored like he's
always saying it does I don't know I
don't know they will never ban us again
by the way shout-out to equals cash I
think I'm getting that name right for
finding that he's the one who figured
out that it was dailymotion you can find
it in his source code
it's dailymotion local but not only that
because Brian Rose will tell you well
maybe the digital freedom platform isn't
about posting maybe it's about live of
its his big little livestream with David
Icke was a live event a million people
he kept saying it a million people guys
this will be streamed to a million
people simultaneously in the world we're
building the technology again this is
about us building something that we can
use for the future
well he wasn't voting the technology he
rented the technology from another
company called de cast now we know this
because during the livestream I looked
in the page source code and the place
where the video player was getting its
data from was from de caste calm now the
cast is a white label company and this
is where we get to our little analogy
for today guys you guys say I'm low
budget low effort come on guys this took
look at this tape that's expert tape
right there that's serious that way
okay so what's a white label company a
white label is a product that doesn't
brand itself because they want other
people who want a brand to come on and
buy their little white label product so
the caste basically says hey you can
come to us we will give you the
streaming solution and then you can just
write your name on it right in this case
digital freedom read Implanon right
we'll write that real quick in this case
we're writing digital freedom beer okay
but there's a problem with all this
right because so he hires out the
streaming technology from someone else
but all the while is sort of saying that
he's I mean it makes it he makes it seem
like it's a platform that he's building
again this is about us building
something that we can use for the future
but it's but it but it's not he just
bought it and let me try to explain what
this is like because I want to highlight
the inconsistency here okay so basically
Brian Rose let's use a beer analogy
right Brian Rose is like a guy who gets
mad at Miller Lite because they stopped
selling him Miller Lite because he's but
chugging it all the time and they say
hey stop that that's dangerous that's
dangerous to your health and he says no
freedom I need I can do what I want with
this this thing and what you're doing is
really more like a public utility you
know everyone needs this product and
you're maybe you've capitalized the
whole market so you have to sell it to
me they say no he goes ok fine
he goes those followers and says hey
guys I want to create a digital freedom
beer I'm gonna create it with your help
give me a hundred thousand dollars wait
no to three hundred thousand dollars
wait no five hundred thousand dollars
wait no seven hundred fifty thousand
dollars wait no a million dollars and I
will create the digital freedom beer
would you be disappointed if you found
out that he took
a pre-existing thing and just slapped
his logo on it and called it the digital
freedom beer like what you wouldn't
wouldn't that seem a little lame like
you're not getting what you were what
you were promised you would get I think
so I mean I think that's like the the
big hilarious thing about this whole
whole project of Brian Rose or London
real or whoever you want to say is in
charge of it what is said to be the
digital freedom platform is just someone
else's platform that he's paying for
which means and this is important that
at any time they can take it away they
can say hey we're not gonna sell this to
you anymore
just like YouTube did right like Brammer
is this whole argument was with the
digital freedom platform will never be
censored they will never ban us again
because they can't do that to us because
it's ours this platform is of the people
by the people for the people but it's
not yours and anytime the digital
freedom platform which is really just de
caste and daily motion can be taken away
from you the same way that YouTube was
taken away from you so what did people
spend a million dollars on that's the
question because it sure wasn't a
platform it was like a one-time thing it
was like you brought your case one case
of white label beer to the party and
like the level of grandstanding he did
with all of this digital freedom stuff
drove me crazy like he acted like he was
the only guy fighting for free speech
you either donated for freedom or you
sat back with your toilet paper rolls
you can be on the frontlines fighting if
you want or you can be fighting for
someone else's freedom who's in the back
with their toilet roll hanging out
saying yes to all of the government you
can be that person if you want I just
don't think this is doing anything and I
think it's a little bit disingenuous
that the platform thing I mean I think
the way it's pitched makes it sound like
it's gonna be more than just a few live
streams until Brian Rose runs out of
money and his digital freedom platform
and you never talks about the platform
again and let's just talk real quick
about the cost thing here because you
know I called the cow maybe monitors
recorded for quality assurances purposes
because I wanted to know I wanted to
know how much does it cost you know to
run on $100,000 livestream and they
quoted us a price basically a hundred
thousand dollars to stream a million
people and the answer is not a hundred
thousand dollars like he said it was
because the cast picked up the phone I
said hey how much does it cost I want to
run a live stream for a million viewers
so I was reaching out because I was
looking to get a custom quote on a live
streaming solution and I heard you guys
can do white-label
streaming solutions so I'm looking for a
quote on how much basically compute it
would be needed to to basically have a
million people co-current live they go
oh funny I know the price right off the
top of my head because I just answered
that question for somebody else and we
just did their live stream on Sunday
roads like three and so they said oh
yeah this is how much it cost 2.2
petabytes
okay sixty one thousand dollars
basically a hundred thousand dollars to
do to stream a million people for about
a million for about 30 minutes that's
correct we just we just had one of those
on Sunday that's why another pricing off
the top of my head
[Music]
[Music]
but never sure the trash
[Music]
Sakura
[Music]